[Music]
in unwanted gains news
story of my life bro what is a unwanted
game but you just get random muscle out
of nowhere - sometimes I just wake up
and I'm like well why would that be
unwanted because it's a different kind
of game oh like that the muscle games
I wouldn't want big balls out of nowhere
the detergent maybe it's just that seat
maybe that thing makes you say some
funny stuff you're the furthest away so
you can't hear mm-hmm submitted by I
want hot cheetos I love what she do that
was my [ __ ] life in high school play
video games and sit there with hot
cheeto dust all over you and [ __ ]
getting touchy Odessa all over you
keyboard what's the difference between
right now sure this you know your
fingertips are stained red permanently
stained red all my [ __ ] game consoles
my PC is just red dust everywhere greasy
ass face and cheeto dust researchers
suggest that obesity may be contagious
sorry guys is that why me a bar got fat
at the same time yeah just like the
people you hang out with like when you
see them eat so much that you want to
eat to the lifestyles continue it's so
funny is it's not like that the reverse
side you know I mean like if some crazy
diet you're just like we this does not
invite that person I wish it was
contagious to work out well people are
on a crazy diet I eat more my huh I
don't know it's like some kind of mean
thing about like Abe can you have this
I'm like that too with Casey cuz kid
who's always trying to eat super clean
like no fats and stuff and shuffles
always on a holiday yeah you know I just
realized I haven't seen Casey and so
[ __ ] long since the wedding
no no it's Christmas I feel like it's
been forever yes so every time he's on
he's trying to get clean I for some
reason I'm craving like worse things
yeah I'm like who we go even when I try
to eat clean I'm craving more style I'll
take my meal prep himself not my [ __ ]
meal prep my I'm gonna be disciplined
and I'm like but I also post meats and
flavors
so he's like what do you want eat I'm
like all this good sushi I mean you're
on a diet he's like did you say pizza
she keeps me accountable I'm like next
week we're eating clean okay she goes
all right I'm like we're doing it I
don't understand the concept of like
when you're dieting you want to see it
so you know ice cream video you miss out
there's also channels for it's like
mukbang yeah people are like can you
stream you eating I'm like why like
really this is social eating and then I
was asking my viewers like why do people
wanna watch that
apparently there are some people who are
on diets who just want to see you eat
gross things like how does that help
like gross thing is like like satisfying
to them oh that just makes me hungry
yeah I remember
okay so back when I was modeling for a
clothing like website it's like it's
like forever21 kind of website right the
photographer was on a diet like us like
I was [ __ ] like juice only diet just
oh and every time it was lunchtime we
have our food she's like can I just like
smell it and watch you yeah I get that
this young the smelling part I get that
yeah like she I don't get the watching
you like eat a whole meal yeah that part
is like so she'll come up to like all
the models like in like we're all eating
and she's like and then like she's like
take a bite and take a bite Jules watch
me that's so sweet
I usually got to the person I got
actually what he does he goes can I have
a box come Johnson just just wonder it
one potato wedge oh yeah you're like if
I watch someone eat then it's already
too much cuz I gotta eat but if I'm like
in a bakery and I smell a lot of like
breads or whatever that's fine that's so
that'll be satisfying but once someone
puts it in their mouth I'm like alright
I gotta buy a bread know unless it's bar
eating cuz there's some people I could
watch eat like we have a friend June and
show like every time sheets noodles she
when she eats it just looks so good but
then if he eats noodles I'm just like oh
[Laughter]
you know why you don't like you because
this boy eat noodles like this what do
we find out why people OBC
this is actually fascinating please yeah
I mean I'm just gonna get to you guys
like the short version of this but give
it to us raw yeah don't give us a
science [ __ ] we're too dumb because it
gets really science with the study and
everything but pretty much back in 2007
researchers researcher says I like
researcher mister sir said I should give
her these hoops
I know these researchers okay
researchers they found that people were
up to 57 percent more likely to become
obese of a friend or family did the same
during that same period of time so that
was in 2007 but then recently there was
this other study that they used twelve
us-based military installations and
you know these military families that
they live on the base so it's a really
tight-knit community they concluded that
when families were transferred to these
bases that tend to have a higher obesity
rate they also tend to gain weight so
but then if you went but is it the
people spa or is it the restaurants
fault because they probably have some
bomb-ass food at that base but
apparently it's like it's sort of
contagious like the behavior of
overeating or whatever behavior is
causing that over what may be it's
because like Debra moved to [ __ ] him
here and then Karen's obese as [ __ ] and
they become friends and every time I
hang up or hang out with Karen so it's
like always like let's eat something and
then well yeah that's pretty much what
they're what they're saying here it's
like with the people that you surround
yourself with that's you adopt a
lifestyle well good that's why I like
when women get pregnant and there we see
the hubby gets fat too cuz they're both
eating this you know what's interesting
apparently I'm not sure how true this
excited do my own research I just
overheard this but like if you are if
both couples are overweight at that time
like you're severely obese like your
genes actually change and you could
actually transmit over to your
epigenetics what so epigenetics is is
gene expression so how how you are at
that state it activates some genes to
get expressed in some to be like subdued
and then so when you reproduce at that
state those are the genes that you're
passing on that's cool every single one
of your kids are so different but if
you're like super fit the whole time
like let's say for a 10-year span all
your kids are pod be fit oh [ __ ] so Tyga
is never gonna be fat Oh depends so they
have they have like Visa they did like
this huge study I think it was victims
of the Holocaust they had very little
food and everyone was surviving during
that period everyone it was surviving
with like 500 calories a day and so the
genes for that were passed on were for
people to be able to survive on very
very low calorie diet after World War
two is over everyone's daily caloric
intake went back to normal
that entire population got fat because
the genes that were passed on were made
to survive on 500 calories now
everyone's taking 2,000 and that's 1500
over more than what the
is that I should continue to get fatter
when I have a kid so when they eat 3,000
calories it's like nothing to them but
also lazy as [ __ ] like you too for
that's the problem
well thank you for that your ancestors
were starving and small and that's why
you're not starving and small yeah cuz
I'd be eating too much delicious yeah
but do that actually look it up it's
pretty cool yeah you control what your
state is you control your gene
expression that you pass on to your kids
oh man no wonder it looks like the way
he is cuz I was like super emotional
when I was pregnant he's a very
sensitive type of kid I was not eating
very well he also doesn't mean all that
well bonded that means del Taco raised
Isaac in your belly yeah the only thing
your Randall why you Del Taco
mom is in the genetics of Isaac look at
Del Taco cheese that quesadilla all that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] grew him yeah he's part
don't [ __ ] about you never had a
chicken soft taco at Del Taco
you get three for two dollars on a
Tuesday or a Thursday even trying to get
that word I'm okay with it though
because I'm still thinking about
chickens soft tacos right now because
you ate the chicken song and then you
put it inside your heart taco yeah and
then you make your own gordita at Del
Taco but it was ten times better because
it had a chicken stock oh yeah good
I really put in that is so good mild
sauce they have a wild haha you asked
him for secret sauces like I'd like this
little thing of like white sauce and
it's so good it's bomb yo somebody show
this del Taco and show him how much we
love them not the flood is incoming now
we're gonna be too thirsty arena drive
them away not thirsty always give it to
us no
[Music]